OverWatch was supposed to save blizzard
we had so much to prove we wanted to
show everybody that you know we we're
not failures we can we can make a game
it's so smooth it's so fresh it's so
Dynamic so responsive it's just
absolutely ridiculous on every level I
mean it is my favorite game let's go
let's go
[Applause]
for one of the most beloved game
developers in the world
is another prime example of what
blizzard is doing wrong people and pro
players scrimmed this meta probably six
to eight hours a day well you know you
want your team to win right they're
gonna have to play What's better at a
certain point I'm like what the hell do
you people want it is not fun it is not
skill this is so bad there are these
moments of regret that you have as a
game developer there was no hope there
was no communication zero at all between
a broken game a waning player base and
enormous controversy it seems like there
was no hope left for OverWatch
[Music]
and yet blizzard got one last chance to
make it right
[Music]
blizzard used to be one of the most
beloved game developers in the world
they pioneered real-time strategy games
MMOs and action RPGs building a massive
fan base with some of the biggest games
out there and in 2007 they began to
expand their empire starting development
on a new MMO codenamed Titan but by 2014
after running into problems during
development blizzard scrapped Titan
entirely blizzard still needed something
new though and a handful of Titan devs
were called on to design Blizzard's next
big IP what they came up with was
OverWatch drawing from the moba's
blizzard helped Inspire and the success
of valve's Team Fortress 2. project
Titan was already a class based shooter
but OverWatch sharpened the concept the
team used assets from Titan to put
together their pitch to Blizzard
Executives getting the green light to
launch of Blizzard's first new IP since
1998. and it's been I think not even a
year at that point that you know we came
off a canceled project and we had so
much to prove we wanted to show
everybody that you know we we're not
failures we can we can make a game the
game was actually fun and you can kind
of see Temple of Anubis is really taking
shape now in terms of level design and
then we were really proud this is just
24 days later you can see the progress
that was made and the whole time here
the UI is evolving the game mode is
starting to work like we actually have
capture points that you can stand on and
at BlizzCon 2014 OverWatch was finally
revealed to the world the wait ends
right now
OverWatch
soldiers scientists adventurers
OverWatch was everything blizzard fans
wanted and seemed like a chance to bring
in new players as well between the
incredible cinematic trailer and the
unique gameplay it really felt like
blizzard had a hit that could reach the
Casual audience too which is something
blizzard really needed at the time
blizzard games were beginning to face
what would become a massive decline
World of Warcraft was bleeding
subscribers Diablo's fanbase was
dwindling after the disastrous Diablo 3
launch and Starcraft had all but
collapsed as an esport taking its large
competitive Community with it Heroes of
the Storm came out in 2015 but
Blizzard's attempt to take back mobas
did not pay off the game just never
found a large enough audience to compete
so all of Blizzard's hopes laid with
OverWatch a beloved wow designer Jeff
Kaplan was leading the charge for
overwatch's development he quickly
became the face of the game reassuring
Blizzard's die hards and in an effort to
appeal to a a wider audience beyond that
blizzard released highly produced
animated shorts about each hero to help
tell their story before OverWatch
launched so by the time the open Beta
hit in 2016 everyone was primed to fall
in love with the game and that is
exactly what happened we're all excited
super excited would you say I'm kind of
super depressed as well because I'm not
playing OverWatch right now it's so
smooth it's so fresh it's so Dynamic so
responsive it's just absolutely
ridiculous on every level I mean it is
my favorite game once I got a Lobby of
friends together I had a superb time if
you play this game with friends we're
willing to work together players support
entertain classes and have fun at the
same time you're going to really enjoy
this game
9.7 million players turned up to try
OverWatch over the span of four days and
when the game officially launched a
couple of weeks later that hype
continued OverWatch was an instant hit
and it wasn't hard to see why the game
was a breath of fresh air in the FPS
space combining powerful and fun MOBA
style abilities with fast-paced
head-clicking action the characters all
felt distinct each with their own style
that made them stand out and easy to
love not to mention the fact that those
cinematics blizzard released in the
months leading up to the launch help
people get attached to the cast before
they even got to play the game and
perhaps most importantly overwatch's
unique game modes forced players to work
together OverWatch launched specifically
without the team deathmatch mode so
common in other Shooters the game
proudly demanded players learn teamwork
and communication to succeed
it was something truly unique so you
gotta put sentries in here
in a Sentry there and just cover the
whole [__] thing in centuries they're
not going to come in here they are how
are they going to come in here oh my God
they killed him they killed her okay
someone's here
all right I don't know if anyone just
saw what I did there but I'm pretty
proud of that my friend got hooked and
so I ran forward with deflect and tanked
the hook for him but even in those early
days there were concerns about the
burgeoning competitive scene it already
seemed like blizzard was struggling to
balance OverWatch I have seen where a
pro meta team composition which enables
maximum sustainability has developed as
one of the best ways to control a point
it's called A 222 setup it has two
winstons two tracers and two lucios and
at one point one of the control games
which is the gameplay you're watching in
the background both teams were running
the same one and if players ever found
themselves in a sudden death situation a
coin flip decided who got to start on a
fence and essentially win the game which
of course nobody liked blizzard started
fixing some of the more glaring issues
with the competitive game mode though
and overwatch's Esports scene began to
grow oh David coming back in with the
Pharaoh Zumba goes down fairly soon but
there's a Primal Rage for Miro you got
to get away
from that monkey wow two mid-air hits
three mid-air hits
goes down in this push is probably going
to get stalled out oh
oh shattered though they're gonna give
him the dad
okay they're gonna try and take High
Ground up they're gonna boost on top of
The High Ground what is this what is
this
that Athena coming down luchakai has no
idea they're coming from this angle it
was starting to look like blizzard had
the next great esport on their hands
until it all came crumbling down
we designed OverWatch from the ground up
to excel as a competitive game we're
looking for the top players in the world
and the team owners who will form the
OverWatch League there will be regular
schedules professional contracts free
agency Baseline minimum salaries and
benefits providing more stability for
teams and players
in November 2016 just a few months after
OverWatch launched blizzard announced
the OverWatch league and while people
were immediately excited for the
possibilities the decision to franchise
before the scene really picked up marked
the beginning of a difficult era for
OverWatch Esports smaller orgs many of
which had helped grow the scene were
unable to afford the reported 20 million
dollar price tag for a spot in the
league and were pushed out of the game
meanwhile the OverWatch League might
have featured some of the game's biggest
brightest Talent sure but had so much
money being thrown around it was
difficult to justify these guys are
getting hey to do this the league
minimum is 50 Grand a year yes and how
high does it go potentially
um so there currently isn't a salary cap
so the scale is as good as and as to me
demand of the players um so the reality
is I don't see these guys any different
um and these players any different than
a LeBron James a Stephen Curry they are
the Elite of the elite at what they do
globally in the early days of the
OverWatch League things were new and
exciting and the plays were amazing few
kills here going in favor of the
Gladiators another half trying to come
through from hydration onto agility so
you know how devastating the hat is now
as Fishers
[Applause]
let's use Earth shutter one fight and
then we'll use zarya on the next fight
and you can kind of stagger those
ultimates I wonder where this Nano boost
is gonna go for New York
oh no way unbelievable he gets knocked
out of the path but it looks like the
Boston Opera is getting too busy trying
to take the point that's the Widow duel
one again Philadelphia Fusion oh it's
gonna come out of the top Striker though
lands a big triple on the barrage there
the graviton helping both support to
court together that's what they needed
but can't be strikes in again
what are you doing this is unbelievable
but as the weeks and months went by it
became clear that the biggest problem
wasn't the Esports ecosystem or the
insane amount of cash in the league it
was the balance a quote that Jeff Kaplan
brought up in his Forum post is that
even if they make the game so balanced
that a strategy or a character is just
one percent better Pro players will say
the character that's just one percent
worse is unplayable and that's kind of
true really that's what it's going to
come down to is it easier to dive or to
counter dive the first year of the
league offered little diversity in hero
picks and most matches featured similar
dive comps it got old fast and it didn't
seem like blizzard had a solution The
Meta right now literally is
ass it is boring as F and just when
everyone thought that things couldn't
get any worse blizzard did the
unthinkable
what's up everyone this is Jeff from the
OverWatch team I am super excited to be
here today because we finally get to
talk about hero 27 who is hero 27 well
it is Brigitte Lindholm brigitta was
incredibly powerful on launch her kit
was the most busted thing OverWatch had
ever seen she was basically unkillable
and players weren't happy how big is the
healing radius like am I healing
oh
no dude now Mickey has a rally if he can
stay alive doing lots of damage giving
his team a good amount to Healing as
well getting a little bit low needs to
be careful here wow he's got the rally
off they actually kept him alive
brigitta is another prime example of
what is going wrong with this game and
what blizzard is doing wrong if you look
at the way she supports she adds
additional Health to characters which is
also a major problem every Hero has a
certain Health meter for a reason right
like that's actually going to be busted
it's going to be extremely unfun to play
Against Savior not really respecting
jay-hong he ain't getting right in his
face in gambler
Xavier will be flailing brigitte's
release marked the start of overwatch's
worst ever meta goats a comp or teams
would pick three support Heroes and
three tank Heroes without a single
damage dealing hero dominated the game
for nearly a year because once again
blizzard refused to listen to the
community this meta led to Long
confusing games that demanded a ton of
skill but were awful to watch we do see
the Outlaws are going to pull out
Dante's Tracer this has been some of the
things that Outlaws fans were waiting
for is a good Tracer player on Houston
it's Jake on the Fara this combo's
worked well for them before but as soon
as they see the defensive setup they
will just simply swap it away crucial
time lost Here For the Outlaws who's
letting the fans give their uh the fans
here in the studio give their opinion
well you know you want your team to win
right they're gonna have to play what's
matter players who had made a name for
themselves for their incredible aim were
forced off of the damage roll or were
stuck warming the bench OverWatch became
the first competitive first-person
shooter where shooting didn't matter
blizzard made an attempt to kill goats
even adding a hero designed to counter
The Meta but nothing changed blizzard
continued to ignore basically any and
all feedback from their player base and
the game felt terrible Chad I cannot
imagine what it's like to be a pro
player right now Chacha I want you to
think of this okay people and pro
players scrimmed this man up probably
six to eight hours a day and it wasn't
just the game's Pro scene that was
affected even some of the Casual
Community was beginning to walk away
from OverWatch in part because the
game's story content was also lacking in
an effort to win back the core fans
blizzard introduced roll Q forcing each
team to have two heroes from each role
and to lock in those roles before a
match started thank God 222 is happening
the game has seen so many different
unique things but I think it's time to
settle down and sort of find like a
standardized way to play the game I get
to play DPS again but since DPS remained
the most popular role outside the pro
scene many players were forced to sit
through ridiculous wait times just to
play the game you know muss is going to
get us to Mars by the time this game
pops
the 2-2 roll lock failed to encourage
diversity at the pro level I've seen
people say well goats is dead
um and now it's just double sniper and
that's gonna be terrible for oh now
everybody's just gonna play McCree and
at a certain point I'm like
what the hell do you people want the
game devolved into shooting at Shields
and players were once again left
frustrated over the fact that years
later OverWatch still wasn't a game
about shooting their enemies simply put
OverWatch just wasn't fun so in other
words you don't want him to eat all the
alts in the game like Diva no yeah makes
sense there are these moments of regret
that you have as like a game developer
and perhaps eating everybody's alt is
one of those meanwhile Blizzard's
decision to sign an exclusive streaming
deal with YouTube decimated the
OverWatch League's viewership between
the miserable games and the declining
audience the multi-million dollar League
began to look less and less like a
viable career path here you go you ready
CS go mini Maps
few balance changes one map many balance
changes right now we get to OverWatch
many balance changes
many Maps it makes OverWatch a big pain
in the ass to figure out after bounce
changes because after every single
bounce change that occurs it changes it
on every single map and the entire map
meta has changed and while OverWatch was
supposed to save the company in most
people's eyes the game was dead and
blizzard was over and yet Perhaps there
was still something left to salvage
I miss you does this mean OverWatch is
back
[Music]
in November 2019 blizzard announced
OverWatch 2 promising to repair the
competitive mode and give casual players
more PVE content but as the years rolled
by and more information came to light
there was one huge decision that left
some members of the community confused
OverWatch 2 will be played with two
teams of five players holy [__]
you think 5v5 is the solution how about
you balance your game instead next time
and while some believe it would lead to
better gameplay the switch to 5v5 forced
every pro team and stack of friends to
ditch one of their players and since the
game was announced three years before
release the final years of OverWatch one
felt Hollow from 2020 on blizzard hadn't
added any new Heroes Maps or basically
any new content to the game aside from a
death match map that nobody asked for
but although they had already given up
on OverWatch 1 the pro scene continued
to give us some of the game's greatest
plays everyone is weak eqo with a blade
pulls it through builds it up will it be
enough one kill two kill are you kidding
me eqo now finds it with us and now it
is overtime actually moving over to the
Tracer to drive
now moving over onto the Widowmaker
taking the clutch into his own hands the
head shot at the head shot at the
headshot but it's on two Hunters they're
winning this one out Muse has fallen
bird ring oh he's gonna be next on the
list there you go taken out straight
away
's been taken out I don't believe that
despite all these incredible moments
OverWatch continued to suffer casual
fans abandoned the game finding it hard
to care about something that was on its
way out they just kept making the same
mistakes over and over and breaking the
game even further maybe this is gonna be
a hard take I think this [__] is the
worst thing
to happen to OverWatch this [__] is
[__] up it is not fun it is not skill
it is [__] [__] it is dog it is
dog [__] this is so bad I don't know
because people are gonna say oh what
about Brig release or what about [__]
uh goats or no this is so bad there was
no lights in that tunnel like that that
tunnel was Pitch Black we were doing
more than fumble in the dark we were
running into walls like it was just not
it was just double shield there was no
hope there was no communication zero
nothing at all but then things got even
worse for blizzard
throughout the summer of 2021 reports
came out about women in the company
being mistreated at basically every
level fans had to reckon with knowing
that some of their favorite games were
made amidst these disturbing allegations
Jesse McCree who an OG hero McCree was
named after was also accused of sexual
harassment leading blizzard to rename
the character and just before this mess
came to light the face of OverWatch Jeff
Kaplan left blizzard leaving players
unsure what to expect from OverWatch 2.
between fans being sick of the original
game competition from other titles like
valrend scooping up overwatch's casual
audience and former stars and the world
being disgusted by blizzard there were
few who had high hopes for the new game
OverWatch 2 launched in October 2022 and
the problems began almost immediately
between server errors concerns about the
new battle pass and of course balance
issues there was a lot to be frustrated
by I knew we could do it awesome yeah
but at the same time there was a lot to
love too players who were able to find
their way into a match found that
OverWatch 2 was better than the original
the switch to 5v5 paid off with faster
more Dynamic games people had hope for
the future of OverWatch for the first
time in years there's no doubt in my
mind that what we have now is better
than what we had then like there's no
doubt in my mind and even when I'm super
frustrated when I'm super angry when I'm
tilted I'm like I can't believe these
players I'm getting I can't believe
these games I'm getting even then you
still got to stop and reflect no well at
least it isn't you know OverWatch one
double shield but still I don't think
there's another game that takes my heart
that makes me like addicted the way
OverWatch does that makes me want to
keep coming back the next day still the
game felt rushed launching with
relatively Bare Bones content and
without the promised PVE mode to some
OverWatch 2 is the same poorly managed
game that they gave up on years ago but
with some small tweaks to others it's
the first step towards redeeming a game
that was supposed to change everything
the original launch back in 26 teen held
so much promise with casual players
lining up to get to know the game's
lovable Heroes and pro players showing
us incredible things on stage but
blizzard has never managed to deliver on
that promise still OverWatch has an
unmatched ability to hang on for another
round the game keeps fighting to be with
the community desperately wants it to be
there is a small chance that OverWatch
does have a future after all the world
could always use more Heroes
oh